hey good humans this episode is brought
to you by tick-tock Before we jump into
the episode we actually want to hear
from one of our favorite tick-tock
creators and a big jublia friend this is
Zara hi I'm Lara I'm an Afghan American
and a child of immigrants my parents
moved to the United States about 26
years ago with hopes of a better life
and more opportunities my siblings and I
opportunities that they never had
growing up in Kandahar Afghanistan
during a time of turmoil throughout
their childhoods my parents faced
countless obstacles and struggles
obstacles and struggles that shape them
into the people that they are today
resilient and hard-working courageous
and selfless and throughout my own
childhood I never had to struggle in
that same way at all but my parents
taught me those same traits that they
grew up with to be hardworking and
strong-willed and resilient and I'm
grateful that I have a platform like Tik
Tok to share that on thanks Sarah make
sure you check her out and other amazing
tick tock critters but downloading the
app tick tock and for now enjoy this
episode it is not so much me accepting
America and becoming an American is more
about America accepting me
[Music]
I am an immigrant and I am a parent born
in India three kids yes I am from Brazil
my firstborn was seven months when we
came in
I am first-generation Nigerian
Cameroonian American I would describe
myself as I thought of immigrants I love
I know exactly where my roots are don't
really hear a lot about child of
immigrants experiences and I really want
to hear from the other side as well from
my parents side I think I want to see
just the love and compassion of each
culture
hey guys I'm Kendra I'm 27 years old and
I'm the casting producer Jubilee and I'm
first-generation Nigerian Cameroonian
American my name is Marco Landon I'm a
student at UCSD I'm 20 years old and I'm
a child of immigrants and I identify as
Asian American I am Fanny I am 41 and
I'm a filmmaker and I grew up in
Venezuela my name is Christine I'm 28
years old and I'm first-generation
Chinese American I am
romi Singh 57 years old I was born in
India and I am an immigrant father of
three children born in America
my name is Surya I'm 54 years old I born
in Brazil and I mother forward
my parents had a good life because
especially my dad they had you know he
had a big family with siblings but you
know he graduated high school really
late because he had no shoes and he had
no support and my mom - she lived in a
in a room with her siblings on my
grandma and they worked so hard and then
they brought us to this country and I'm
very very grateful my parents grew up in
Cultural Revolution China so they always
tell me that you know they didn't have
the opportunity to go to school and
that's why they came here so that my
brother and I could and have the
opportunity that they did not have and
birthday parties - like my mom doesn't
actually know when her birthday is
because they don't like keep track of
that in camera so we like joke that it's
like December 31st maybe but like I had
I had birthday parties growing up and
like my father fought in a war when he
was 11 when I was 11 I was watching
Nickelodeon like okay you know I didn't
I didn't have the same experiences as my
parents growing up I am very
appreciative because I was able to go to
school my mom that was unable to go to
school they have to leave their home
country this time I guess on top of
everybody what everybody's saying aside
from the money aspect I feel like I was
able to be more expressive here I'm like
openly queer I also talked about my
mental illnesses pretty openly and I
feel like that's something my parents
were never able to talk about like I
know my father and my mother both
suffered from abuse as well so a lot of
the things that they've gone through
they feel like I feel like they had to
internalize and not really been able to
really express or find proper treatment
or care for these um certain things I
don't think my parents had to go through
a few things as I had to go through with
my kids my parents had to deal with
things that are not showing up home at 8
o clock for dinner and I have to worry
about making sure the kids don't get
into drugs or into some other bad habits
looking back what it would have been or
could have been had had been back in
India I think those are big things that
I would say
so when I was like 11 or 12 my dad tried
to take my sister and I to ebo classes
that's the language that they speak in
his tribe in Nigeria and nothing made no
sense in one year and out the other
I think also to a lot of like the
cultural norms of like Nigerian Cameroon
I don't agree with for example hitting
your kids is acceptable and I don't
agree with that and I do not like that
about how that's how I was raised my
father passed away I was six so for my
mom and my brothers really kept the
culture and thanks to them that I was
able to learn the Arabic language but I
never been back home I truly feel like
I'm missing out on it I think for me
it's that I don't feel necessarily Asian
enough nor do I feel necessarily America
enough I've know that a lot of my Asian
friends would say I'm very whitewashed
and when I speak Cantonese or Chinese
leo why do you say it like that or you
don't know how to say that and then when
I have non Asian friends they would say
oh like you're very Asian like more like
you use chopsticks or oh you only want
to get Asian food all the time so then
there's always like these other people
always chiming in about me and my
cultural identity that I never really
get a chance to really define myself in
that maybe I miss understood the
question because I definitely identify
with you know not feeling American
enough or not feeling Asian enough but I
feel like when I think cultural roots I
think like family values that my parents
instilled in me you know being kind and
you know being generous and taking care
of family and like those kind of
principles my father the grandfather for
the kids he lives with us my mother
passed away and then he came to live
with us so that's the other connectivity
we have to the culture and you know we
do things simple things like you know my
kids when they're home they have tea
with my dad every evening at five
o'clock and so and that's when the talk
and I think that's the other connection
we have because we are a
multi-generational
okay for me because my parents are in
the states too so they really you know
my dad makes that it buzz and you know
we have a whatsapp group with my family
and I check it every morning and they
keep me updated to what's happening and
I try hard to instill that and my kids
it's hard do you feel like the only way
to keep that is through like
generational ties because I didn't grow
up with grandparents all of my
grandparents died by the time I was
seven so I didn't know anyone my past
family and my parents siblings like most
of them have passed away as well
certainly a way to stay connected but
for example there's a group of
Venezuelans in LA that we meet and we
keep in touch every city I go to I make
it a point to find the one Venezuelan
restaurant like I mean you could
definitely dig and it takes work but I
think it's important having the
privilege to grow up in America being
around people of different cultures and
backgrounds and just diversity I feel
like I wouldn't be the person I am today
if I wasn't able to meet the people I
met or even just talk to the people I've
ever talked to
I didn't grow up in a family that spoke
the same language at all my dad speaks
ebo my mom's takes a combination of like
pidgin English and French and I only
know English my parents always make this
joke like we taught you English whenever
I try to correct them when they say
something like well we're the ones who
taught you English so that's the only
language that we can all connect through
I think also my parents wanted me to
assimilate into the US as much as
possible so everything they said and
everything that they ever read and was
in English
and even the TV shows like every time I
would kind of maybe put on like an HK TV
like Hong Kong TV or something like oh
no tried Nickelodeon I tried Cartoon
Network mainly because they didn't want
me to feel ostracized because they knew
like I can like 1st or 2nd grade a lot
of kids wouldn't mock me when I would
like speak Chinese my mom speaks English
and my dad does not so a lot of times
I'll communicate in both and my friends
will hear me on the phone and I'll go
from Chinese to English and they're like
you're speaking English I'm like I am
like my parents understand both and
sometimes I'm disappointed in myself if
I can't find the Chinese word because I
feel like I'm losing my Chinese you know
I speak with my family in Spanish my
brother tries to talk to me in English
sometimes and it's weird it just feels
weird why are you talking to means
English you know but then with my kids
it's been so difficult to teach him
Spanish and they went to Dual Immersion
school and you know when they were
little I was like you cannot learn
Spanish because I want you to be
bilingual but he's very very difficult
and I think now that are a little older
they're they're trying to learn Spanish
yes I love talking to my sister who also
speaks three languages and depending if
you want to exchange some secret even if
in front of our kids we usually you know
speak in whatever language the others
don't understand but also helps helps
being connected back to where you come
from till you find yourself changing and
you're speaking I can do this very
easily yeah without knowing well there's
certain things you can say in English
easier
in Spanish and vice-versa like the word
for love in Spanish we have like 10
words for love you know in English is
love you know some things that are
easier in a certain language but is it
bad that I don't really want to speak my
mother tongue that much it's mainly
because like it's tethered to like
really negative emotions my father was
abusive towards me so I love the yelling
and a lot of the conflict and a lot of
the screaming was all done in Chinese so
whenever I hear Chinese now I associate
that immediately with that violent
household so that's why I like even one
of my friends I love to speak Cantonese
to me it's like that's awesome
yay but I don't really want to speak to
back because it's associated with such
anger but there's a billion people in
China right there I'm not denying what
you went through right but I think you'd
be missing an opportunity but it's a
little different so both mark and I
speak Cantonese which is largely I would
say a dying language because only people
from Hong Kong where they're small
southern part trying to speak Cantonese
the majority trying to speaks Mandarin I
love being able to speak Chinese to my
parents because sometimes there's things
that are more easily expressed and my
parents always try to teach me the wait
like different ways of life and
different principles that can only be
said in Chinese because if they're said
in English so like I'm like you think
differently right yeah differently so I
think that's the opportunity really to
really look at the world a little
different yeah it's more expensive
I think the best thing is that I can
really bring knowledge to them there
that things aren't done the same way
everywhere because I grew up differently
I was born in the States but I left when
I was a baby and I grew up in Venezuela
so it's very interesting to see how my
kids are growing and how I grew up and I
feel sometimes they're missing out on
certain things but I also see all the
opportunities they're getting that I
didn't I mean my parents are pretty open
people we talk about anything my mom
went through depression and we were
there for her at first we thought she
was making it up so that might have been
like culture but you know what time we
started to learn about it and this a
great um there's a great system here for
mental health so I think I learned a lot
and like I said my parents and I talked
about everything
we're very open with each other I think
mental health and a lot of Chinese
American household is ignored mainly
because you know my parents never had
that outlet to share how they felt to
speak up because they always had larger
things going on in their life like
trying to survive cultural revolution
China how I interpreted it is if I was
feeling depressed or some type of way I
could tell my parents now would they do
anything about it no because in Africa
well that I notice you know this is from
like I watched I grew up like watching a
lot of Nigerian movies when someone has
mental health problems they call it like
oh they just have an evil spirit in them
they need to get the evil spirit out you
know I'm not saying that people there do
not have it but it's not talked about
there's a pride there
and I know this cuz I'm pretty sure my
dad has had depression since I was born
and like me and my siblings recognize it
now but like he would never the thought
of saying hey Dad Dean do you want that
there every maybe we should see a
therapist completely off the table why
would I go see a therapist I'm fine if
you have a roof over your head you have
clothes on your back you're fine I'm
fine I mean it's a whole saving face
culture as well in Chinese culture like
you can't let someone see that you're
weak like any emotion is weakness so no
matter what it is just be strong and if
you can't be strong pretend like you're
strong and just get over it you're up to
right Kendra you know it's like if
somebody is emotionally disturbed they
would say they're you know they have a
bad spirit or there would be a common
term given that he's a crazy right but
it's only about a few decades since now
we actually are giving labels to
specific diseases associated with the
mind so for me I never had a chance so
I'd never had the need to discuss this
yes I feel like that's the question I'm
gonna have to answer like in a few years
I feel like when I'm at a place where I
want to be then I can say yes but
reflecting on where I am in my life
right now I don't I don't know if I'd
necessarily say it made me better
because I still feel like I still feel
like there's a lot of a pattern of how
they were raised and then their parents
were raised and their parents are raised
with how they raised me and it's a lot
of like struggles and difficulties I'm
trying to deal with now as an adult
living in America as opposed to Nigeria
Cameroon I've been here since 86 I came
in yes my speaking English and I learned
with my children everything else that's
why I feel like I'm more American now
then I am Brazilian or there I am Arabic
I was naturalized I raised my hand but
raising the hand and when you swear
allegiance it's not enough I think you
have to really feel it here and you know
I've been here since 85 one year more
than you and for me it is not so much me
accepting America and becoming an
American is more about America accepting
me and making me part of this country
and I just feel lived most of my life
here you know my kids were born here
everything has been good to me so I feel
very much as an American here although I
was born here like distinctly like
American I feel like I identify more
with Asian American but even then that
term is very murky since being Asian
isn't enough for my Asian friends and
being American isn't enough for my I
guess American friends I when I was 17
and
to this country and I was taking my
college entrance exam and I was supposed
to check a box to say wife in this area
was or what nationality and there was
not an ash that was in a box for
Venezuela and obviously and that was the
first time ever I was confronted with
selecting my ethnicity so even though
I've lived in this country longer than I
lived in Venezuela
I am constantly being told where are you
from where is that accent
even though my accent is extremely mild
and so just like you said I do feel like
I'm American because I'm from South
America I'm North America so I feel
double American but the fact that I am
constantly being asked where I'm from
and that I don't have a say because I'm
not from this country even though like
my kids are from here I live here I pay
taxes I don't know how anybody I just
have to be blind like any one of you
feel American not in this time not in
this country because it's a constant
thing it's not always line you know some
people are generally just curious and I
think very negatively like you speak
Chinese like we're in Asia are you from
like and I take it as a opportunity to
educate them like I mention American my
parents are from China I was born here
and you know I do speak Chinese but you
know I was born here I'm American it's I
take it more as a question of curiosity
and and rather than a question of of
trying to put you down
so my father is a Sikh and when 9/11
happened he felt very scared for his
life so I am NOT a Sikh I don't feel a
turban my father does you know if I if
you ask me personally I feel safe
sometimes I don't know if my family is
safe if something bad was to happen
because my father wears a turban because
he's a Sikh I don't know I don't know if
that will spill over into my household
yeah my children you know two boys so I
they're Latinos you know I do have those
concerns but that being said I can speak
here I can be in this video you know in
Venezuela I'd be put in jail I think
it's not just the color of our skin or
the way you speak but we get judged
allow so by our names because that that
was really hard for my children growing
up in school I I had experienced a lot
too from my name my color scan the way I
look and and it's just it's how we gonna
take that and deal with we can make it
worse than it than it is or we can make
it better no my parents are Palestinian
they're from the Middle East
[Music]
yes I think it's beautiful
there is the good of each culture and
there's some challenging of each one of
them too for my girls
there are certain things that they
couldn't do so that was a challenging
for me being a mom I think so there's a
lot of things that my parents did you
know we traveled a lot because they
wanted to really encourage learning they
actually went to university in the US so
I think when they went back home and
they raced us they had a little bit of
the influence from the US but I do love
like you know 9:00 p.m. was bedtime I
did that with my kids or family even
religion culture we have same values so
yeah I do try to race them very similar
same here I think I am Who I am because
of my parents I I know they did the best
they could and you know there are things
that we do things differently I mean we
live in a different world right now I
mean there were times that the biggest
occasion for us in a month would be when
we go and watch a movie together as a
family now it's you standing and talking
back there it can be watching something
on YouTube right so it's a completely
different environment how you raise the
children again you have to adapt to the
new environment but the values the
culture what it takes to be a good human
being I think that baseline remains the
same
yeah that's a hard no for me and it's
because I was raised to fear my parents
a big part of it too was just a lot of
what Americans would consider abuse I
never wanted you know discredit like
anything that my parents have done
because I understand that this is the
best that they could do and they did try
to raise me the best that they could but
even then I felt like there was a lot of
holes that didn't need to happen my
brother and I never was both out growing
up and they pay for a college and they
did everything that they were supposed
to you what I wish my parents did that
if I have kids I would do for is you
know tell them I'm proud of them ah
sorry guys and you know I'm part of them
all the time even though we're not close
and sometimes I feel like we just need
to hear it back like that they're proud
that we went to college and our good
functioning in this world I was raised
by my mom and my brothers I had three
brothers and they are all very
restricted even getting up and looking
through the window for my mom there was
no no I could not even do that or go to
the store by myself oh no someone is
gonna kidnap you so yeah I was a stay
home mom so I took drove my children
back and forth to school and to their
activities so I feel like it was
different the way they were raised and I
was I was raised with more restriction
even though I was raised in Brazil but
my mom was like she has a lot of wisdom
when I look back now to the way she was
so restrict she did the right thing
that people that watch this video if
they can relate thought they speak up
I hope it's far as a conversation that
they themselves can find a mutual
understanding between their parents or
their kids thank you so much for
watching I hope you guys enjoyed that
episode just as much as I did feel free
to follow me on take talk at Muslim
Thicke and have a great time
thank you Sarah if you want to check her
up make sure you download tik tok and
follow over content she's amazing and
maybe one day you'll see jublia tik tok
as one let us know what you thought
about the episode in the comments below
make sure you hit the like button and
subscribe and we will see you next time
[Music]